et puis côté politique à présent les
yvelinois seront appelés aux urnes pour
élire leurs représentants de leur
circonscription à l'assemblée nationale
les 12 et 19 juin al'approche du premier
tour des élections législatives la
rédaction de tv 78 vous aide à y voir un
peu plus clair nous faisons le point sur
les enjeux de ce scrutin à venir dans
les yvelines et focus aujourd'hui sur la
9e circonscription c'est avec vous c'est
une charles beau soir en soir donc à ce
que vous pouvez déjà nous dire quelles
sont les communes qui sont concernés par
cette 9e circonscription oui bien sûr
elles ce site ou situe plutôt dans le
nord ouest du département on dit d'elle
que c'est une véritable petite france
elle est essentiellement rural mais
concentrent aussi de grands pôles
urbains elle se compose du coup de 88
communes réparties en 4 content quand on
le canton d'aubergenville de bannières
sur scène de guerville et de houdan plus
les communes des mureaux et de chapet et
le représente à peu près cent quarante
et un mille habitants alors c'est une
circonscription qui a toujours plutôt
pencher vers le centre droit d'abord
avec le rpr rassemblement pour la
république puis l'ump représentée par
henri cuq de 1986 à 2010 puis sophie
primas jusqu'en 2011 c'est ensuite jean
marie des tares du parti les
républicains qui occupera le poste de
député jusqu'en 2017 enfin en 2017 c'est
bruno millièmes alors qu'on saigne et
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france sous
l'étiquette modem qui a été élue battant
le député sortant à plus de 54% et
justement un candidat qui se représente
incertaine et will effectivement
candidat à sa propre succession sous
l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle donc sous la bannière
ensemble qui regroupe sept partis
politiques dont la république en marche
alors il faut savoir que la 9e
circonscription regroupe beaucoup de
communes qui avaient accordé leur voix
au rassemblement national au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
principalement dans le conte ans dans le
conte ans de bonheur sur scène les murs
aubergenville avaient quant à eux voté
majoritairement jean luc mélenchon avec
36% aux mureaux et 30% à aubergenville
au premier tour le député sortant a donc
beaucoup de travail à faire pour
retrouver la confiance de ses habitants
et il y aura aussi très autres candidats
donc sept sur sept circonscriptions
c'est là où il ya le plus de candidats
dans les yvelines et oui en fait ils
sont beaucoup à ceux discutés la 9e
circonscription six femmes contre 8 tom
au total alors parmi les autres
candidats on retrouve babette de
rozières conseillère régionale
d'ile-de-france depuis 2015 alors c'est
un ancien soutien de valérie pécresse
qui elle avait quitté en pleine campagne
présidentielle
aujourd'hui elle dit représenter la
majorité présidentielle alors qu'elle
n'a eu aucune investiture officielle le
député sortant lui a demandé de modifier
ces tracts de campagne sans succès pour
l'instant à droite c'est pauline
winocour lefebvre membre du parti
républicain qui représentera le parti de
l'union des droites pour les yvelines
conseillère départementale du conte haut
du canton d'aubergenville 2015 et vice
présidente du conseil départemental
délégué à la ruralité l'agriculture et
l'alimentation elle se place comme la
principale concurrente du député sortant
à gauche c'est un membre de la france
insoumise victor baia qui représentera
les nubes la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale à seulement 20 ans
c'est un étudiant en 3e année de
philosophie à la sorbonne et le conte
axé sa campagne sur l'écologie et le
bien-être animal on retrouve également
le conseiller régional d'île de france
laurent morin pour le rassemblement
national qui se présente comme la seule
opposition à emmanuel macron christain
fluo pour le parti reconquête d'eric
zemmour ou encore philippe baumard pour
le parc pour le parti la lutte ouvrière
merci beaucoup céline charles pour ses
explications journalistes pour tv 78